en el ojo de la tormenta a menos de 40
días de su Asunción luego de un viernes
convulsionado la prensa británica
arremetió contra la primera ministra Y
cuestionan cuánto puede sobrevivir en el
cargo el estallido sucede tras la salida
de suministro de economía cuasi cuarten
en medio de la convulsión de los
mercados y la caída de la libra
esterlina tras presentar su mini
presupuesto su reemplazo Jeremy Hank
experimentado hombre fuerte del partido
conservador reconoció errores en el plan
fiscano
fue un error recortar la tasa impositiva
máxima en un periodo en el que pedíamos
a todos que hagan sacrificios y fue un
error volar a ciegas y no respaldar los
planes económicos que se anunciaron con
un pronóstico independiente de la
oficina de responsabilidad
presupuestaria ambas cosas han sido
abordadas
aceptó que el gasto público no aumentará
según lo inicialmente deseado y que
inevitablemente algunos impuestos
deberán aumentar con un perfil opuesto a
cuarte respaldo al rival detrás en las
últimas consultas internas pero su
llegada responde a la necesidad de
calmar a los mercados y recuperar la
confianza en la capacidad de tronos como
líder sin embargo la premiere no es
mirada de rojo solo puertas adentro el
líder laborista Kirk starmer aprovechó
la oportunidad en momentos en que su
partido encabezan las encuestas
Reino Unido está clamando por un
liderazgo claro y los laboristas deben
proporcionarlo
el partido conservador sabe que Trust no
puede arreglar el lío que ha creado
y en el fondo saben que ya no tienen un
mandato del pueblo británico
en tanto que la ministra principal de
Escocia Nicola sturgeon pidió por una
convocatoria de elecciones
cuanto antes la gente tenga la
oportunidad de deshacerse de este
gobierno que está causando tanto daño
mucho mejor
la figura de Trust se ha visto socavada
en poco más de un mes y crecen las
especulaciones sobre cuánto podrá
resistir manejando una situación que
parece fuera de su control